so let's say we're going to play a game
where on each person's turn they're
going to keep rolling this fair
six-sided die until we get a one
and we just want to see how many roles
does it take so let's say we define some
random variable let's call it x and
let's call it the number
of rolls
until
we
get
a
one
so what's the probability
that
x is equal to 1. pause this video and
think about it
all right the probability that x is
equal to 1 means that it only takes us
one roll to get a 1. well that's going
to be a one sixth probability
well what's the probability
that x is equal to two
well that means that we on the first
roll we get something other than a one
so that is going to be 5 6
and then on the second roll we get a 1
so that has a 1 6
probability
and we could keep going what's the
probability that x is equal to 3 pause
the video and think about that
well that means we miss on the first two
so we have a 5 6 chance of getting
something other than a 1 on the first 2
rolls so we could say that's 5 6
times 5 6 or we could write 5 6 squared
and then on the third roll we have the 1
and 6 chance of getting the 1.
so
times 1 6. and i think you see a pattern
here and you might recognize what type
of random variable this is this is a
geometric variable now how do we know
that well each trial or each role is
either a success or a failure every time
we roll we either get a one or we don't
we have the same probability of success
of rolling a one each trial these are
independent trials
and that there's no set number of trials
it could take us an arbitrary number of
trials to get the first success so
that's what tells us that we're dealing
with the geometric random variable
now one question is is what is going to
be the mean of this geometric random
variable well we proved another video
where we talk about the expected value
of a geometric random variable we're
really talking about the mean of a
geometric random variable
and it is a little bit intuitive if you
were to just guess what is the mean of a
geometric random variable where the
chance of success on each roll is 1 6
you might say well maybe on average it
takes you about six tries and you would
be correct the mean of a geometric
random variable is one over the
probability of success on each trial so
in this situation
the mean
is going to be one over the probability
of success in each trial is one over six
so it's equal to six so one way to think
about it is on average you would have
six trials until you get a one now
another question is what's a measure of
the spread of a geometric random
variable and we don't prove this in
another video maybe i'll do it
eventually that the standard deviation
of a geometric random variable is the
mean times the square root of 1 minus p
or you could just write this as a square
root of 1 minus p
over
p
now in this situation what would this be
well the standard deviation
of this random variable this geometric
random variable it's going to be the
square root of
1
minus 1 6
all of that over
1 6.
so this is going to be equal to the
square root of 5 6
over 1 6 which is equal to 6 times the
square root of 5 6 and this is going to
be approximately equal to 5
divided by 6 is equal to that we'll take
the square root of that and then
multiply that times 6
gets us to about 5.5
so approximately equal to 5.5
and what's interesting about a geometric
random variable obviously the lowest
value here in this case is 1 2 three can
go higher and higher but it can go
arbitrary you could get really unlucky
and it might take you a thousand rolls
in order to get that one it could take
you a million rolls very low probability
but it could take you a million rolls in
order to get that one and so another
thing to realize about a geometric rand
variables distribution it tends to look
something
like this
where the mean
might be over here and so you have a
very long tail to the right of your mean
and this is classic
right skew
and so all geometric random variables
distributions are right skewed they have
a long tail of values and infinitely
long tail of values they can take to the
right
now one last question instead of dealing
with a six sided die what would be the
situation if we were dealing with a 12
sided die what would then be the mean of
our random variable and what would be
the standard deviation of our random
variable pause this video and think
about that
well the mean would be 1 over 1 12
because you have a probability of 1 12
every time of getting a 1 we're assuming
we're playing the same game now with the
12 sided die so 1 over 1 12 would be 12.
so on average it would take 12 rolls to
get that first one and then our standard
deviation is going to be essentially
this times the square root of 1 minus 1
12. okay let me write it this way it's 1
minus 1 12 over 1 over 12 which is the
same thing as 12 times the square root
of 11 12.
11 divided by 12 is equal to
take the square root and then multiply
that times 12 and you get about 11.5
11.5
and so you can see with a 12 sided die
it has the same pattern where you have
your mean of your random variable and
then you have a standard deviation
that goes
a reasonable bit on either side of the
mean it's almost equal to the mean in
actually in both situations it's a
little bit lower than the mean but then
there's many many many values that go
far to the right of your mean and so you
have this classical right skew for a
geometric random variable